[Music]
game of thrones season 9 will definitely
happen in near future because not only
did the showrunners leave space for
someone to make it
but they also left quite a few big clues
in the finale they are hinting at huge
plot twists for some of the biggest
characters
like denny's resurrection return of many
words for successional over westeros and
jon snow being the new king beyond the
wall
beside that very well written and
executed season 9 of game of thrones is
the only thing that can redeem game of
thrones at this point
because season 8 was so bad and
disappointing that it killed
re-watchability of the show
for so many people but if there would be
a season 9 and it would actually be good
and
answer many unanswered questions then
season 8 would be nothing more than a
bad season with great previous seasons
and with a great final season i'm aware
that hbo could not do anything but
obliged with david and dan's wish to
make
only 8 seasons and they actually wanted
10 which was because david and dan were
the ones who had the rights to the
story's adaptation
now when they are done with it hbo could
and should then probably will in near
future
make a sequel or as i call it season 9
to continue the story and repair the
damage that's been done to the game of
thrones
thankfully david and dan left so much
space for it not having given answers to
almost anything in season 8
not wrapping up so many stories and
leaving so many clues for what we can
expect to happen with most of our
favorite characters
as well as leaving clues to what might
happen all over westeros as well
let's take a look at what we can expect
to happen in the future sequel or season
9.
from dennis hinted an almost confirmed
resurrection
to wars across westeros to all the
characters we expected to see in the
season 8 and play the vital role will
actually appear
and play their vital role in season 9
dwight walker's story back in the game
jon having yet to fulfill his purpose
and the dragon queen's revenge
various joke on taking kill danny was
the question which was answered then the
end of the finale
and i made a whole video explaining it
right after the show ended which was a
huge hit
i mean the video not the ending
obviously in that video i also explained
why drogon is taking her to that place
and what it means
in disappointing season 8 finale jon
finds himself with no choice
but to kill dany the mad queen
influenced by destruction of king's
landing
but also by tyrone lannister who
convinced him that his family will never
be safe as long as danny lives
anyways jog on having a connection with
his mother came to the scene
and it was a heartbreaking moment drogo
nudges her tries to wake her and it
breaks my heart
having destroyed the one thing that made
his mother dany mad and evil
drogon gently lifted his mother with his
claws and flew away across the narrow
sea
one question remained where exactly did
drogon take dany
sam answered that question in the small
council towards the end of the episode
when king bran asks for an update of the
drogon's whereabouts late in the finale
sam says he was last spotted flying is
toward volantis
before brawn cuts him off and drogon
any word he was less spotted flying east
farther away the better what this means
is that dany's fate is left up to a
debate
she's dead and she might stay that way
but she might also be resurrected by the
red priestess quinmara
who happens to be at the same city
drogon was last spotted flying towards
in fact i think the showrunners wanted
to imply to us viewers that danny will
probably not stay dead for long
why else would they mention drogon
flying toward volentis they could have
had drogon flying toward valyria where
targaryens originate
this could have been a possible
destination for them both seeing as it's
fair the targaryens traditionally lived
in their dragons
second they could have had drogon flying
toward dothraki sea
drogon and his dragon siblings were born
in the tracky territory
and they could have had him flying back
to the place he feels his home
but they didn't they specifically
mentioned drogon flying east towards
volentis
so why volentis and what's in volantis
the first time we see volantis is in
season 5.
as tyrion and varys were making their
way through a market they spot a red
priestess preaching to a crowd of slaves
who catches tyrion's eye as he stops to
listen to her sermon
she preaches that the lord of light has
sent them a savior the dragon queen
danny targaryen who's been waging a
campaign against slavery in marine
it's not just a city where people love
and support dany but more importantly
volentis is home to kinmara
a red priestess who made a brief
appearance in season 6
to lend her support to the team dany she
met here in lannister and varies in the
great pyramid
of marine tyrion asked her people to
rally behind annie
to ask them to seek her as their
protector and guardian not a conqueror
quinmara was happy to assist tyrion
saying dany is the one who was promised
from the fire she was reborn to remake
the world dany has been sent to lead the
people against the darkness in this war
and in the great war still to come
quinoa promised to spread the word about
khaleesi throughout essos
so we know that the followers of the
lord of light stand behind dany
including kidmara whose titles read
flame of truth the light of wisdom and
the first servant of the lord of light
the high priestess of the red temple of
volantis she is one of the highest
ranking of roller clerics
since she firmly believes that danny
targaryen is the princess that was
promised
and the one who will make this world a
better place much like melisandre
believed in jon when she resurrected him
could it be that dany will get
resurrected by kinmara in my opinion
it's an
obvious yes if no they would not mention
drogon flying toward volantis
which we know is basically the capital
of the lord of light religion
a place filled with red priests who
worship dany and most importantly that's
where dany's biggest supporter among the
red priests
and also the most powerful of them all
quinmara is
i think this is exactly the same how
they ended jon's story as well
jon goes back to the wall and takes the
black even though there's no need for
the night's watch anymore
jon knows this and tells tyrion that
it's ridiculous the order even exists
because there's no need for them then in
the closing montage he wears black
but he also goes beyond the wall with
torment ghosts and bunch of wildings
yes johnny is wearing black much like
danny's dead but it's implied that he's
not coming back to the wall
but is rather staying beyond just like
how it's implied that dany will not stay
dead for long
because the place where drogon is taking
her to volentis
pretty much means danny will get
resurrected jon becomes the king beyond
the wall and dany the queen of essos
that's an ideal start of season 9. then
his storyline would be about her
resurrection
her realization that essos is where she
belongs
but also her seeking revenge for those
who wronged her after being resurrected
dany with drogon and kinvara by her side
would go from valentine's to marine
where she left daario in the second sons
in charge danny will decide to rule
lands in essos where people love her
instead of westeros where she is feared
and hated same as jon when john was
resurrected
danny will not want to rule something
where people don't appreciate her and
love her
she will rule essos instead where she is
their misa her ultimate goal is to be
the queen of essos based in marine
because those are people who deserve her
but before that she will seek revenge
as i said jon snob did avenge his own
death upon being resurrected as well
then his list includes jon who killed
her tyrion who made jon do it
and sensaku pretty much started all of
it by revealing jon has the best claims
to tyrion who then told it to wear is
and that's when the whole plot against
her started since i was a little finger
student
she knew this would cause dany's
downfall and danny herself recognized
that as well in episode 5 of season 8.
why do you think sansa told you
what do you think she hoped to gain she
trusts me yes
she trusts you she
trusted you to spread secrets
that could destroy your own queen
and you did not let her down she will go
to westeros with drogon quinmara dario
and his two thousand second sons
as well as remain on saline and dothraki
to seek revenge
against those who plotted and executed
her just like john did after he was
resurrected
the unsolid numbering 4 000 heavy
infantry at the end of season 8 left for
noth
but i'm certain they will go back to
dany upon finding out she's alive again
the dothraki numbering 50 000 light
cavalry according to the official report
left king's landing for essos and will
also without a doubt continue to serve
their khaleesi when they find out she's
not dead after all
and just like that dany has the greatest
army numbering 56
000 in dragon along with her advisors
quinmara grey warm and dario
in season 9 i would imagine dany is
driven by revenge
less naive and more calculated basically
she will go against half of the kingdom
the north ruled by sansa the westerlands
ruled by tyrion
but also against riverlands and the vale
who will support the north
as there are stark's relatives the crown
lands will also support them as bran
stark rules it now
and he will help his sister the ridge
that is now ruled by braun would also
support him
since it's tyrion and bran who gave him
those lands and titles but i doubt braun
will be lord paramount
of the reach for long there is no way
all the proud houses of the reach would
be okay with some random sell sword with
no noble blood or claim to the rage be
their lord
bran would definitely end up dead in a
ditch as soon as he showed up to claim
highgarden
then the high towers or red wines would
declare themselves either lords of
highgarden
or even kings of the reach and make it
independent dorne and the iron islands
would then follow as well
but even if all these kingdoms don't
declare independency
that still doesn't change the fact that
both the iron islands ruled by era
greyjoy
and dorne ruled by the new prince of
dorne would definitely pledge their
support dany
when they find out she's been
resurrected in the season 8 episode 4
prince of dorne pledged himself to dany
and i believe he would honor that pledge
if no dany can always win his support by
marrying him
as we all know that's the best way to
make allies two kingdoms are left to
declare their support too
king beyond the wall jon snow is an
obvious one den is coming to kill him as
well so he joins forces with sansa and
bran stark
it would also be nice for season 9 to
show why jon's true parentage was a big
thing
except for being a plot to make dany
paranoid giving it some importance as
well as showing us what was the reason
jon was brought back to life because he
has not fulfilled his purpose yet
beric dondarrion did and died in the
process melisandre fulfilled her purpose
as well
did not die in the process but died when
it was done
jon snow didn't die he's still alive
meaning he still has a role to play a
purpose to fulfill
stormlands and its lord gintry is a
complicated one yeah he's a good friend
of starks and jon snow
but they're not the one who legitimized
him gave him those titles
and lands it was dany and i believe his
honor will bound him to help dany
after all tyrion did tell dany that the
lord of storm zen who will be forever
loyal to you after she legitimized him
fitting reward for a hero and a lord of
storm's end who will be forever
although dany is coming to avenge her
death as i said earlier she doesn't plan
on ruling westeros
that's a good parallel with robert's
rebellion in both cases the throne was
not the main goal
but at the end when the vengeance is
over someone has to rule it
i think that's when gendry comes in for
dany she doesn't want to rule westeros
she just wants revenge but someone will
have to rule it when the war is won and
that's when gendry comes in
to secure his loyalty i believe she will
promise gingery the throne
melisandre prophesied that genji will
make kings rise and fall
we didn't see him making kings rise and
fall in season 8 perhaps revealing
season 9.
we all know how accurate mel sanchez's
prophecies turned out to be in the end
all of this makes for the bloodiest war
in westeros the argument that bran stark
this powerful three-eyed raven could
stop any of this happening before it
actually happens falls in water
because if he was that powerful then he
will stop the night king before he
actually happened
bran couldn't even work into the night
king's dragon so there will not be any
use of him when dany comes back
he lives in the past mostly i live in
the past
in season 9 we could also see many
important events that we were promised
to see in game
of thrones but didn't we could finally
see bran's visions of the past of
robert's rebellion
robert versus rhaegar as well as reiger
targaryen's reasons to run away with
leona stark
without saying a word to anyone what was
the reason behind them too
not telling everyone they're in love but
instead rehgar made it seem like he
kidnapped lyanna and started the war
that would destroy the targaryen dynasty
perhaps we could also find out more
about the white walkers than the night
king as well
something that bran is surely eager to
find out himself
as he said it himself bran stark lives
mostly in the past now
spending much of his time in greensite
so getting to see some of the mysteries
unravel is always
a good choice perhaps season 9 would
also bring the white walkers back into
the fold with the night's queen
we know that the night king was killed
and destroyed in season 8
along with the white walkers he created
and the wights he and his lieutenants
created
but that doesn't mean we've seen the end
of the white walker story
the season 9 could introduce us with far
more powerful and complex character than
the night king
the night's queen there are many other
parts of the story that season 9 would
include as well
such as zarya stark's adventures i would
expect the return of joking
and especially the return of quaithe who
i believe dany will meet after she is
resurrected
all in all season 8 left a lot of space
for season 9 or some kind of a sequel to
game of thrones
we told the clue sit left behind and
especially with that confirmation that
drogon is taking dany to valentine's
fair quinmariz
danny supporter and the most powerful
follower of the lord of light
far more powerful than melisandre who
brought jon back
why else would dragon be flying to
volantis that's not where they were born
that's not their ancestral home that's
not where they lived the only connection
dany has with that place is the red
priest who supports her
and who has the ability to resurrect
people all the characters we expected to
see in season 8 and play the vital role
we could see in season 9.
everything left unexplained could be
explained and most importantly we could
get a satisfying ending to the series we
all fell in love with
we definitely will not get the season 9
anytime soon
but i believe we'll get some kind of a
sequel to repair the damage done to both
game of thrones and hbo perhaps a
trilogy
but something will definitely follow up
on where season 8 left